i used to live in southern california  and when we had very little money one of  my favorite things to do with the kids  is i would take them for a day trip to  mexico and because you could go and it  was an adventure you'd go down 50 bucks  you could eat lunch you could get some a  couple of knick-knacks and drive back up  super cool right  so it's his first time down and he is  pinned on 10. he's  so excited ha to be there right boy am i  glad i don't do that anymore  and we get there and he turns to me  we're there for about half an hour and  he goes  dad i love mexico  everybody here is so smart and i was  like  i said what makes you say that man he  goes  they all know how to speak spanish and i  was like oh my god  and this is why ladies and gentlemen i  am referred to as the dumb one